曹雪芹写《红楼》人物总有一种淡定闲进的分寸感。写文章能写到举中热轻的地步。经临时才揭游学游肉,而且将人物的深度刻画隐藏在看似不经意的小小细节中。曹雪芹就是这样刻画李文的。李文的精神世界往往被读者忽视。我们只看到李文是假诸的妻子、假兰的母亲。
假诸早早去世后,李文一人扶养孩子长大,这符和封建时代真女的标准。我们很难看到李文内心世界的征长,但曹雪芹却写到了这一点。
对此有一个很好的切入点,便是《红楼》第38回,螃蟹燕。
史乡云驻东,学宝猜请客,在大观园里大摆螃蟹燕,重人吃蟹饮酒好不畅快。
李文在有了些酒意后,阴间王西放有凭而这个左绑又闭,就情不自惊,像众姐妹发了几句牢送。
李文道,想当初你诸大爷在日何曾也没两个人,你们看我还是那容不下人的,天天只见他两个不自在。
所以你诸大爷一没了,趁年轻我都打发了。
若有一个手的柱,我道有个绑币,说着低下累来。
众人都道,又何必伤心,不如散了到好,说着便都洗了手,大家约往家母王父认出问安。
曹雪芹仅用这一段文字,就把李文内心深处的孤独压抑,吸属清洩出来。
这段最妙之处在于,刻画李文的精神世界不用正写,而用他人的反应。
当李文向众人说起往事时,中姐妹的反应是,又何必伤心,不如散了到好。
大家解散这场验惠,以打断李文迭迭不休的轻素。
当然,从交际原则来看,这些姐妹们也没有做错什么。
一方面,李文的身份是大嫂子,等于半个长辈,她久后所说的话,又涉及到自己的个人家庭。
其次,现场的小姐们,如待遇,保拆,碳春等人,接待自归中,尚未出价。
李文把双居生活中的不如意,讲给她们听,她们无法敢同身手,只能解散这场验惠,让李文停止捞倒。
縱关红楼梦前八十回,李文迭一次正面发现,发生在第三十三回,不效种种大成吃塌。
家宝欲遭父亲假证滚帮教育,王夫人敢来求情。
见假证心如铁石,王夫人想起以去世的大儿子假诸,便声声哭喷。
王夫人抱着宝欲,直见她面白气弱,底下穿着一条绿沙小衣,皆是血字,
惊不住解下汉金汉,由囤至尽,或亲或子,或整或破,尽无一点好处。
不觉师生大哭起来,苦命的儿让,因哭猪苦命而来,忽又相其假诸来,便叫着假诸哭倒,若有你活着,便死一百个我也不管了。
此时里面的人,文德王夫人出来,那李公才王西风,与英春子妹早已出来了。
王夫人哭着假诸的名字,别人还可,唯有公才尽不住也放声哭了,假证听了,那内诸更似滚刮一般滚了下来。
这是李文唯一一次,不被他人反感的发泄自己的伤感,这种发泄对他是一种奢侈。
日常在家母王夫人面前,他无论如何不敢谈论跟假诸有关的任何话题,
这只会引起他们的伤感情绪,而让老太太不高兴,后果可想而知。
事实上,如果不是这次保育挨打,王夫人主动哭喊出假诸的名字,
李文恐怕根本不会有机会,展露自己的内心世界。
李文虽然生活在万子千红的大官员内,可这并不能腐卫他的精神世界。
正因如此,他才会羡慕假保育有习人,王西方有评论,假母有冤养,
并在久后无比伤感的感叹自己身边,没有一个得用的人。
第63回一红夜夜,在假保育生日宴上的抽花间游戏中,
李文抽到一只老梅,写着双小寒子四字。
一面就是是,竹离谋舌子甘心,
助于自隐一杯下家智头,
这是对李文独善其身的一种暗示,
其他精采的花间,或是大家共和,或是上下家营久,
李文确实独已,对于这个花间,李文自己也很满意,
所以他笑着说,真有趣,你们志去吧,我只自吃一杯,不问你们的废语心。
李文这种不问他人费心的心理,
必然跟他在中国府内的生存处境有直接关系。
宋然他享受到了珠大奶奶,英有的丰厚物质待遇,
他的内心始终是空虚的,无人关心无人填补。
以目前,李文结局研究的现状来看,
似乎李文最终行为有愧。
急证据是红楼梦曲,晚少华中的那句,
只这带猪关批凤狗,也抵不了无常性命。
所以说是,人生末售老来平,也需要因智即而孙。
幕下红楼研究中有一类观点认为,
李文最终对败落后的假家人是若无赌,是了因智。
所以曹公才对他这般批判。
但我们若是深入探究李文的内心世界,
他的行为模式是符合人物心理动机的。
将不问他人的废语心,作为处事标准的李文,
是不会主动摊火别人命运的,
就像没有人考虑过他的内心世界一样。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,
我们下个视频再会。